[Music]
this is true recently a man on a flight
to Paris was arrested for taking off his
shirt and urinating on another passenger
you read that strange is mind-boggling
it's insane I mean what kind of twisted
creep takes off his shirt on a crowded
plane in urinates on another passenger
it's just nuts that you would do that
[Applause]
hell was that but Billy Billy that's art
director Billy why don't we just cut to
that guy oh sorry just a camera miss you
but Billy don't you think that's a
pretty bad time to have a camera missed
you
you're right all right I apologize sir
I'm really sorry about that that's
embarrassing and ridiculous and
completely unprofessional I'm sorry all
right so back to this story this
unhinged pea freak apparently what he
does Billy what the hell sorry Conan I
put a post-it note on the camera button
to remind myself not to do that again
and what's the pressed it too hard okay
let's get something straight get it
together Billy all right that's wrong
that's really bad okay you got it okay
good so anyway this complete perv
relieves himself on a flight and he just
totally
they were sounded there were sound
effects to that liquid pouring and
exactly ah yeah and then cut to the same
guy how do you explain that Billy
I can explain it's pretty hot in the
booth so I poured myself a rupiah it was
refreshing but it must have left my mic
open my bad that if I am real explains
it but it's still it's completely
unprofessional I know no more Singh okay
good
so anyway this I come the yeren
terrorist yes Lee has the captain has
turned off the no urinating light so you
may now freely urinate about the cabin
Billy Billy I thought you said no more
mistakes that wasn't a mistake that was
a snafu okay listen
that explains absolutely nothing there
was it Curtis explains nothing please
yeah please stop torturing this poor guy
in the audience he has nothing to do
with this story in fact we have a photo
of the actual guy who peed on this
airline passenger check it Oh
[Applause]
please really explain that did I already
use nothing you use snaps oh yeah it's
nothing I don't know what's going on the
booth it needs to stop now no more
mistakes that humiliate this innocent
guy in our audience so you mean nothing
like this congratulations on behalf of
our airline I'm proud to enroll you in
our frequent Tinkler program Thanks
sir
thanks for peeing the friendly skies
digit passengers this got these old
ladies with Battle Creek bring this vein
right over me let's go despite all the
good fight to keep down the eye
it ended really nicely with a great song
we come back rob lowes here's hey thanks
for watching please subscribe to my
youtube channel so they will stop making
me shoot these videos please